this is a map of european colonial
possessions in the early to mid 1700s
and you immediately see a few things
spain has a lot of territory in central
and south america
even the small country of portugal
because of its prowess during the age of
exploration a significant amount of
territory in what would become brazil
but they also have possessions in
colonies along the coast of africa and
even things in india like goa
you have the british having possessions
in north america things that would
eventually evolve into the united states
and canada at this point in time france
also has significant possessions which
will later be taken by britain and then
an independent u.s as it grows across
continental north america
but the thing to notice in this map is
despite these significant possessions
much of the world is not controlled by
the europeans yes england also is
starting to have a bit of a colonial
possession although at this point it's a
corporate possession in eastern india in
bengal but much of africa and asia is
not under european control
but then as we enter into the second
half of the 18th century and especially
the 19th century something important
happens in the scope of human history
and that's the industrial revolution or
maybe you could say the industrial
revolutions
now there's many technologies that are
central to the industrial revolution but
probably most important is the steam
engine although you could contend maybe
it's the steam engine maybe it's
electrification maybe it is the
telegraph but the steam engine all of a
sudden allows us to harness the power of
really coal to create steam to turn
engines and then these engines could be
used to power factories so that you
could amplify what human labor could do
before this factory right over here
looks like they're creating fabric from
some kind of thread or they might be
sewing of some kind and a human equipped
with a power loom or with a sewing
machine could produce much much more
than they could have ever produced
before by hand the steam engine and
things like electricity also create a
revolution in transportation the
transportation of goods and people but
also the movement of information
this right over here is a picture of a
steamship which you could use for trade
but you could also use it to project
military power this here is a railroad
similarly transport goods and people but
it also allows you to keep control over
a larger swath of territory and this is
a telegraph and then a telegraph all of
a sudden for the first time in history
you can communicate across the globe in
a mere instant
and what used to take months to figure
out what was going on could now happen
in seconds so once again this is
valuable for trade but it's also
valuable for coordinating military power
so in large part to these revolutions
that we're seeing and we will study more
in other videos the map of the world
looks very different roughly 150 years
later this is what the world looks like
around the year 1900 and you immediately
noticed some differences from that
previous map
most of those colonial possessions in
north and south america are now
independent but you notice something
dramatic happening in africa and in much
of asia
africa has now been carved up by the
colonial powers in the salmon color you
see where the british have control in
much of south africa and then around
egypt and sudan and parts of east africa
you see the french have control of
algeria and much of eastern africa what
started off for the british as a
corporate possession in eastern india
has now grown to become a possession of
the crown you have india part of the
british empire even japan which is one
of the first asian countries to
industrialize is in on imperialism it
has control in korea and in taiwan
so why
this kind of imperialism there's always
the standard motivations for imperialism
that we've seen throughout world history
if you have conquest
that leads
that leads to more land
plus people under your rule
and if you have more land which is for
the most part used for agriculture well
you're going to have more
taxes and wealth
so taxes and if you have more people
they will have output so you can tax
that but they can also be used they
could be taxed so to speak for war they
could produce
more soldiers and so the more revenue
and soldiers you have well that can help
you just accrue more and more power and
so this is the classic loop that you see
why most empires tried to expand and
sometimes when they stopped expanding
you see that they started to decline
but now in this video from the early
18th century to the beginning of the
20th century we have new things at play
we have the technological
innovation
from the industrial revolution things
like electricity and steam power you see
the notion of capitalism
come into its prime this focus on where
do you maximize your returns for a given
amount of capital that you have
and land is a form of capital but as we
will see or as we saw in some of those
pictures as technology becomes more and
more valuable things other than land
become very important forms of capital
like factories like railroads like ships
and related to these two ideas you have
industrialization
which is the use of technology to become
more productive to increase output and
they all feed off of each other a
capitalist says how do i get a better
return on my capital well
i should industrialize i should make my
factories more efficient well to make my
factories more efficient i have to also
invest in technology to get that
industrialization
the more i industrialize the better my
profits and so the more i am going to be
able to invest in this cycle as i'm
trying to industrialize i have all sorts
of problems that i'm trying to solve so
it's going to drive the need to improve
my technology and those who develop the
technology well they're going to have
more capital to invest so once again
it's creating this cycle which is going
to feed the fuel of imperialism
think about it in the industrial
revolution the owners of a capital
started to have more and more
power if you think about a factory so
that's my factory right over there
it takes raw materials
raw
materials if you think about it's a
clothing factor it might take raw cotton
or turn it into thread or it might take
that cotton thread and then turn it into
some type of fabric and then you have
finished goods maybe this is clothing
so even before the industrial revolution
people would take raw materials do
something to it and then you would have
finished goods but now this center
portion is being supercharged by
technology by industrialization it is
really becoming the central focus and
it's becoming
more productive so as it becomes more
productive there's a hunger for more raw
materials where do you get those raw
materials from well if you're a small
country like the united kingdom or japan
your raw materials are limited but
there's the rest of the world and
especially the rest of the world that is
not at the same level of technological
sophistication yet so you can perhaps
use your military in order to
force them to trade with you
similarly what do you do with all of
those finished goods you have limited
markets on your island but what if you
could sell to the hundreds of millions
of people who aren't directly in your
country this desire for more raw
materials and more and cheaper raw
materials and this desire to sell your
goods the outputs of industrialization
this to a significant degree drove this
imperialism this colonization and in
general a motivation for freer trade in
general when the free trade didn't
happen freely sometimes it was forced on
the country that was being traded with
and as alluded to already the technology
which helped fuel this industrial
revolution also made it easier to
control a far-flung empire before the
industrial revolution a country like the
united kingdom being able to control
this far-flung empire this would have
been impossible for the romans or the
persians to do using their technology
but now you have the steamship
you have railroads
you have the telegraph
which are parts of this industrial
revolution but they also allow you to
project power and project power much
quicker and much more efficiently than
ever possible
so once again technology
industrialization and capitalism these
were the fuel of the industrial
revolution they provided the motivation
for colonization for imperialism and
freer trade in general but then that was
able to be enforced because of that same
technology you could project your power
through those steam ships railroads and
the telegraph